and the expected police action in ottawa
comes just days after ontario police
successfully broke up another blockade
in windsor our sean o'shea watched that
operation unfold at the ambassador
bridge and he joins us now from the
protest in ottawa so sean given what you
just witnessed in windsor how do you
expect the police operation to go there
in ottawa
well it's going to be difficult and
different jeff for a few reasons one
the weather we're seeing right now but
in windsor you know you had trying to
get people away from a roadway that was
at the end of a bridge it wasn't in the
middle of a an urban center people were
able to come and go as they pleased um
it was much different it was much more
easy to control here you've got people
that are coming from other communities
from other parts of of ottawa and of
course that's what the police chief
talked about in this press conference
today the fact that starting now they're
going to set up a hundred checkpoints to
declare this safe zone so that people
will have to pass through these police
checkpoints provide identification or at
least give some kind of an idea of why
they're going into that area do they
live there do they work there do they
have good reason to be there the idea is
to try to cut off people from coming
into this area where we are unless they
have a real reason to do that all the
while while police try to get rid of the
trucks and the protesters who are here
right now jeff and sean we can see that
snow really coming down there now what
impact could that winter storm have on
the police enforcement
well our chief meteorologist in toronto
here at global says 30 centimeters of
snow expected just tonight and it just
started snowing jeff not that long ago
it's pretty nice day earlier so what it
means is imagine trying to tow trucks
trying to remove vehicles in an area
where the weather is bad or you got a
foot of snow that's what they're going
to have to contend with the thing is
that the people who are still here right
now jeff these are people who are
diehards many of these people have been
here for three weeks they're the most
committed of the people that are
involved in this protest and this action
they are here for the cold but this
weather is going to make it all the more
difficult the police said that they had
a lot of tow trucks available that might
be somewhat modified because of the bad
weather that we're going to face here
it's going to be quite a weekend jeff
sean o'shea reporting from a snowy
parliament hill thanks sean